Весь український антрацит видобувається на непідконтрольних Києву територіях
так званих ЛНР та ДНР
Через два роки Україна зможе повністю відмовитися від антрациту
і перевести енергоблоки українських ТЕС
на газову групу вугілля
вважає профільний міністр Ігор Насалик
Чи відповідає дійсності те,
що Україна зможе відмовитися від антрациту до 2019 року?
Газове вугілля та антрацит – це різні марки вугілля
що відрізняються температурою згоряння та іншими властивостями
Це як дизель і бензин.
На антрациті працює половина українських вугільних ТЕС - 7 із 14-ти
Одна з них на окупованій території
На підконтрольній Києву території фактично
4 приватні та 2 державні ТЕС, які використовують антрацит
Кожна теплоелектростанція має декілька енергоблоків
З них загалом півтора десятки потужністю до 200 мегават
понад два десятки енергоблоків потужністю 300 мегават та один на 800
За словами експертів, перевести з антрациту на газове вугілля
один енергоблок коштуватиме від 150 мільйонів гривень
і знадобиться півроку-рік
На початку серпня один з енергоблоків
Зміївської ТЕС, що на Харківщині
вже перевели з антрациту на газове вугілля
Тривають роботи над ще одним енергоблоком
На думку експертів, теоретично маленькі енергоблоки
можна переобладнати за два роки
Але немає жодного досвіду з великими
і невідомо, скільки це коштуватиме і скільки часу знадобиться
Крім того, на приватних ТЕС
поки що повністю не будуть відмовлятися від антрациту
Приміром, на Луганську ТЕС, що належить компанії Ріната Ахметова ДТЕК
антрацит постачається з Росії через близькість до кордону
Для них економічно невигідно завозити газове вугілля з інших регіонів України
або імпортувати з інших держав
Нині більшість приватних ТЕС не проти відмовитись від антрациту
утім не ставлять собі за мету зробити це найближчими роками
Частка антрацитних ТЕС у виробництві електроенергії в Україні
не більше 12-15 відсотків
і їхня поступова зупинка на переобладнання
не матиме негативного впливу на всю енергосистему
стверджують експерти
Державні ТЕС зможуть відмовитися від антрациту до 2019-го року
Але можна буде перевести з антрациту на газове вугілля
лише частину маленьких енергоблоків державних ТЕС
потужністю до 200 мегават
Це 30-40 відсотків
А решту доведеться законсервувати і не використовувати
до повернення непідконтрольних Києву територій та вугілля
Якщо, звісно, до того часу антрацитові шахти не зупиняться і не затопляться